Soviet dictator Joseph Stalin knew how
to get rid of history he didn't like he
just erased it that's one history lesson
the left has learned very well the
obsession was scrubbing America's past
is in overdrive this time even in Texas
the Dallas School Board voted yesterday
to change the names of three elementary
schools named after Confederate generals
robert e lee Stonewall Jackson and
William Coble in an Orwellian use of
doublespeak one school trustee said
dropping the names was needed in order
to acknowledge history no replacing
historical names and toppling statues
isn't acknowledging history
obviously it's erasing it so why pretend
these historical figures even the
Confederacy just never existed why do
that well of course slavery we all know
was abominable and evil but what do we
learn about the past by forgetting the
past America paid a dear price in blood
to overcome her original sin and our
children have a right to their entire
history and not some redacted version
that omits the important but cautionary
tales